SPEAKER: Kubeflow is
all about creating
a portable and scalable
environment for your machine
learning workflows.
Let's take a look at
how to set up and get
started working with Kubeflow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today, we'll talk about how
to set up Kubeflow and then
go through a deployment.
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link below to read
more about setting up Kubeflow.
Now, one of the key
goals of Kubeflow
is to be portable so you can
run your ML workflow anywhere.
More specifically, it can be
run anywhere Kubernetes can
be run, which is a
whole lot of places,
like running a Kubernetes
cluster on-prem or a managed
Kubernetes service in the cloud.
You can use the Kfctl command
line interface to set up
Kubeflow on your cluster.
Kfctl is flexible so
you can install it
on a variety of environments.
But it's a command
line tool, and it takes
some additional configuration.
So let's take a look at
another way to install.
We'll go with the GUI option and
use the Google Cloud deployer.
This quick form
can get you quickly
set up with Kubeflow after just
filling out some information.
Once we click the Sign
In with Google button,
we'll be prompted
for some access.
Since Kubeflow will be deploying
resources to our Google Cloud
project.
If you don't want to
use this web deployer,
check out that link below
for other ways to deploy.
Now we can see the specific
information needed to deploy.
The first thing we'll need
is a project to deploy into.
If you're just playing
around with Kubeflow,
I recommend creating a
new Google Cloud project
so you have a safe
sandbox to play around in.
There's a link in
the description
to help you through
that if you're not
familiar with creating projects.
In addition, you'll need
to be a project owner
and make sure this project
has billing enabled,
since a default
deployment currently
comes with more resources
than the free trial allows.
Don't worry.
You can always
remove the deployment
when you're done testing
things if you'd like.
The first box is where we'll
put the ID of the Google Cloud
project where we want
to deploy Kubeflow.
And the second contains the
name for the deployment.
We could change it if
we had multiple clusters
or other tools in the project.
But the default
name is Kubeflow.
So let's leave that as is.
There is also another
option for how to connect.
You can choose IAP, which
stands for Identity Aware Proxy,
or just choose a
username and password.
If you're just playing
around and learning,
go ahead and choose Username
and Password to save some time.
Otherwise, you'll
want to use IAP
for things like your
production environment
and to protect any
sensitive data.
After that, you can choose
your zone and version.
Or just leave them as is
and click Create deployment.
This could take up
to half an hour,
but you'll see a window
pop up at the bottom
with a bit more information
about what's going on.
Behind the scenes, Kubeflow
is creating all the resources
you'll need, including the
Kubernetes cluster and service
accounts.
Let's switch to a deployment
that we've already created.
After logging in with our
selected connection option,
we'll get the
Kubeflow interface.
There's a lot of
options here, and we'll
start to go over the
different components and dive
into some of them deeper
in our next videos.
Just to make sure
everything's working,
let's quickly launch a
Jupyter notebook interface.
First, choose a namespace
in the top left.
One will be created for
you through the setup.
After that, just click
on Notebook servers
and click New Server.
We can give it a simple name
like Test and then launch it.
It can take a few
minutes to launch,
since it's handling all of the
work of creating the computing
resources you'll need to run it.
Once the notebook server is up,
we can connect and then create
a simple Python notebook.
As you can see,
everything is working.
And we haven't had to run
any commands to create
the necessary resources that
are needed to run the notebook.
It can be pretty straightforward
to set up Kubeflow,
and it helps distract
you from the manual steps
when growing your ML workflows.
Don't forget, you can
go to Deployment Manager
in the Google Cloud Console to
delete the deployment if you
want to shut everything down.
Just take a look for
the deployment name
you specified in the web UI.
The default name
is just Kubeflow.
In the next video,
we'll talk more
about the different
components in Kubeflow.
Check out the links below
to try it out for yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]